[Music]
justin bieber is back in studio 8h
the singer delivered a powerful
performance of holy on saturday night
live
marking his second appearance this year
i don't do well with the drama
no i can't stand it being fake
oh no no no no no no he was joined on
stage by chance the rapper
the two took us to church performing in
front of a blue
neon cross towards the end of the song
bieber was overcome by emotion
as he bent over while chance embraced
him
yeah that's my guy issa rae made her
hosting debut
and introduced justin's second
[Music]
performance
[Music]
the singer belted out his song lonely
while walking through the halls of
snl studio he then ended up back in the
spotlight where collaborator benny
blanco was playing the piano
justin recently just dropped the music
video for lonely where he turned back
time to his
never say never era everybody knows my
name
now but something about it still feels
strange
like looking in the mirror trying to
steady yourself and seeing somebody
else the video stars fourteen-year-old
actor jacob tremblay
as a young biebs struggling with the
pressures of fame
jacob nailed justin's signature look
complete with his iconic side-swept hair
and purple hoodie they criticized the
things i
did as an idiot kid when justin
announced the release of the music video
he wrote on instagram i went into the
studio and sing through it which wasn't
easy but started to really see the
importance of telling the story
jacob tremblay is so talented it was
emotional to see him play me from the
outside looking in
but it wasn't all work for bieber in nyc
an eyewitness told et that justin and
his wife haley
enjoyed a date night before his snl
return
the couple had dinner at carbone and
quote sat
at a table that was very private and
socially distant from other tables
and they wore their masks when they
weren't seated
they were so cute together haley was all
dolled up in maroon leather pants
and a sheer top with a leather trench
and justin wore a fancy sweatsuit
according to the eyewitness they were
quote deep in conversation
but it seemed lighthearted